THIS MEETING TO ORDER AT LEAST
CALL THE ROLL.
BUT A MONTH THIS EGGMAN HERE
THAN A MONTH AS EGGMAN PRESENT
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON PRESIDENT BURKE
[inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
MEDINA.
LACKEY.
LACKEY PRESENT QUIRK SILVA
[inaudible]
SILVA PRESIDENT.
ALRIGHT WE DO HAVE A QUORUM --
I IT WOULD BE --
TIE ME FOR SOMEONE TO MAKE A
MOVE ON THE CONSENT AGENDA
PEOPLE ARE SO INCLINED.
SECOND IT'S BEEN MOVED BY MISTER
PATTERSON SECOND BY MISTER
LACKEY SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT ITEMS.
THAT WOULD BE SB ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO BY PAN THAT WOULD BE L. S.
BEAT FIFTEEN OH FIVE BY.
A THE THE KEY GEO COMMITTEE AND
S. B. FIFTEEN OWN NINE THE
GOVERNOR AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
BILL.
THE MOTION IS.
DO PASS AND REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS BUT
A MONTH AS EGGMAN BELLOMONT THIS
EGGMAN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE BURKE [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
LACKING LACKEY AYE MEDINA QUIRK
SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
ITEM IS PASSED --
WOULD COHEN A SENATORS WE ARE
LOOKING FOR CENTERS SKINNER.
LARA AND GLAZER COME TO PRESENT
.
WELCOME SENATOR SKINNER.
THANKS SO MUCH SHARON MEMBERS
OKAY SO TODAY BEFORE AS YOU ARE
GOING TO BE PRESENTING SP. NINE
EIGHTY FOUR CORRECT THANKS SO
MUCH SO. NINE EIGHTY FOUR IN
THIS A PERIOD OF TIME WHERE
WE'RE MY THINK INC GROWING
AWARENESS OF THE FACT THAT WHILE
WE HAVE WORK TO EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES --
FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS THAT WE
STILL HAVE A PRETTY SERIOUS SOME
WHAT THEY REFER TO AS CLASS THE
CEILING I WOULD JUST SAY
BARRIERS.
AND WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR PRIVATE
SECTOR CEOS.
COMPOSITION OF BOARDS AND WE
EVEN LOOK AT THEIR MEMBERSHIP
FOR LEGISLATURE WE STILL DON'T
HAVE.
A FEMALE REPRESENTATION THAT'S
ANYWHERE NEAR.
OR PORTION OF THE POPULATION NOW.
ONE COULD DEBATE WHETHER THERE
NEEDS TO BE --
REPRESENTATION EXACTLY
PROPORTIONATE TO POPULATION AND
THAT IS A PERFECTLY LEGITIMATE
DEBATE BUT CERTAINLY WHEN WOMEN
MAKE UP 51% OF OUR POPULATION
AND YET WERE --
IT IN CORPORATE ENTITIES TO NO
LESS THAN 4% OR SO IN THE
LEGISLATURE 20% ARE UNDER.
THEN YOU CAN SAY THERE'S YOU WE
NEED SOME CORRECTIONS SO THE
POINT OF MY BILL IS TO HAVE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SUDDEN
EXAMPLE AND BE A LEADER IN THIS
QUEST.
AND THROUGH THAT TOO BOTH OPEN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WOMEN BUT ALSO
TO HOPEFULLY SEND A MESSAGE TO
PRIVATE SECTOR PUBLIC SECTOR.
THAT WE THINK IT'S REASONABLE
AND APPROPRIATE A RIGHT TO HAVE
A STRONGER REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN.
SO WHAT THE BILL DOES IS IT
RECOGNIZES THAT THERE'S A NUMBER
OF STATE BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
THAT HAVE APPOINTMENTS THAT
WHERE EITHER THE LEGISLATURE OR
THE GOVERNOR APPOINTS THAT
MEMBERSHIP.
AND SO WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL IS TO ENSURE THAT AT LEAST
440% OF THE MEMBERSHIP OF THOSE
APPOINTED BOARDS.
OUR WOMEN --
AND THAT IS ON OR AFTER JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR SO
WE'RE MOVING AND IT'S WE HAVE
SOME TIME.
AND THAT IF THERE IF THE BOARD
IS SMALL SO EXACT FOR EXAMPLE IF
IT'S ONLY A FIVE MEMBERSHIP
BOARD THAN A MINIMUM OF TWO
WOMEN IF IT'S ONLY FOR
MEMBERSHIP BOARD A MINIMUM OF
ONE WOMAN.
SO THAT'S THE WHAT THE BILL DOES
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF IT AND IT
ALSO RECOGNIZES THAT --
THERE'S A LOT OF RECOGNIZES THAT
GENDER IS NOT A FIXED CONCEPT
AND SO IT ALLOWS.
FOR SELF DEFINITION OF ONE'S
GENDER.
AND WITH THAT I'LL ASK MY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT TO SPEAK.
FIRST PERSONS BECAUSE SUPPORT
PLEASE.
THAT MORNING THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS PAUL GOT BACK I AM
THE FOUNDER WOMEN SERVE ON
BOARDS.
A MOMENT THAT ENCOURAGES FORTUNE
FIVE HUNDRED COMPANIES TO BUILD
LIVERS BOARDS THAT OCCLUDE WOMEN.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
A QUOTE RIGHTS ADVOCATES I HAVE
WRITTEN THE BOOK AND REGULAR
THEIR SPEAK RIGHT AND TRAINED
PROFESSIONALS ABOUT BOARD
SERVICES.
GOVERNMENT GOVERNOR BROWN HAS
RECENTLY APPOINTED ME TO THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION.
LET ME JUST BECAUSE THE BENEFITS
FOR WOMEN TO SERVE ON GOVERNMENT
BOARDS TO GIVE THEM LEADERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES WHICH MAKES HIS
BILL VERY IMPORTANT. ONE
GOVERNMENT SERVICE OFTEN
GARNISHED PUBLIC VISIBILITY AND
MAY PROVIDE RECOGNITION FOR
OUTSTANDING SERVICES ON THE JOB.
TOO MANYGOVERNMENT BOARDS TOUCH
SUBSTANTIVE AREAS OF LAW
BUSINESS AND COMMUNITY AND
THAT'S PROVIDE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN NEW SUBSTANTIVE AND
LEADERSHIP SKILLS. THREE
OVERSEEING THIS AGENCIES.
AND PROJECTS CAN PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GROWTH
RESPONSIBILITIES SUCH AS
INCREASED LEADERSHIP BUDGET AND
MANAGEMENT SKILLS. FOR SERVICE
ON GOVERNMENT BOARDS HELPS TO
BUILD A REPUTATION OF INTEGRITY
AND ETHICS BECAUSE MEMBERS OF
THE GOVERNMENT BOARDS ALL ARE
ULTIMATELY ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
PUBLIC.
FINALLY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WOMEN
WERE NOT TALKING ABOUT MINORITY
BUT TALKING ABOUT 50% OF THE
POPULATION THIS IS WHY THE
COMPOSITION OF EACH APPOINT AU
OF WHAT A BOARD AND COMMISSION
IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA.
IS MAKING PROGRESS TOWARD GENDER
PARITY [inaudible]
IN CONCLUSION --
I WANT TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS STATISTICS FROM UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
OFFICE KNOWN AS GO.
IT WILL TAKE ABOUT FORTY TWO
HUNDRED YEARS TO TO REACH PARITY
IN THE UNITED STATES ON
CORPORATE BOARDS SO LET ME PUT
IT IN PERSPECTIVE I'M.
THIRTY SIX IN FORTY YEARS OLD
THE SEVENTY SIX IN A HUNDRED
YEARS I WILL BE.
A LITTLE OVER A HUNDRED LET ME
GIVE YOU ANOTHER PERSPECTIVE MY
YOUNGER DAUGHTER IS SIX YEARS
OLD. FORTY YEARS YOU'LL BE FORTY
SIX IN THE HUNDRED SHE WILL BE
OVER A HUNDRED SO THE
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT.
WOMEN NOT REACH PARITY IN MY
LIFETIME IN HER LIFETIME AND AND
AND THAT IS UNFORTUNATE.
THIS BILL IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
DELUDE BY EXAMPLE AND SHOW THAT
THE REST OF THE NATION.
WORLD AND CORPORATE AMERICA HOW
INCLUSION IS DONE RIGHT AND HOW
THAT IS MORE IMPORTANTLY DONE IN
OUR LIFETIME. FOR THIS REASON WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AS BEING NINE
EIGHT FOUR AND FOR EACH YEAR I
WILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT NEXT SUPPORTER IF
YOU COULD JUST BE BRIEF THIS
DOES ENJOY MY RECOMMENDATION.
OKAY GREAT I HAD A GOOD MORNING
AUDIBLE CHAIRPERSON AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TONY
SAYS SOME OF CURRENT FELLOW WITH
THE WOMEN'S POLICY IS A TO
THROUGH THE WOMEN'S FOUNDATION.
AN ALUM OF THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM I'M HERE TO
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON ONE KNEE --
AS BE NINETY FOUR BY SENATOR
SKINNER WITH A BRIEF WORDS OF
THE ONE OF THE FIERCEST WOMEN
THAT I KNOW A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE RUTH BADER GINSBURG.
SHE STATES WOMEN WILL HAVE
ACHIEVED TRUE EQUALITY WHEN MEN
SHARE WITH THEM THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF BRINGING UP
THE NEXT GENERATION.
ASHIS COOPERATE SINCE THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND IT'S
INFLAMING THAT IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A WITH ALL THE ADVANCES
THAT WE HAVE MADE FOR WOMEN THAT
THIS FIGHT CONTINUES.
ARE KENTUCKY I MEAN NOT
CONNECTICUT FLORIDA AND KENTUCKY
MISSOURI NORTH CAROLINA AND MANY
OTHERS I GENERALLY REQUIRE
APPOINTING BOARDS TO HAVE --
DIVERSITY BUT ALSO THE INCLUDE
GENDER EQUITY HAS BEEN NINETY
FOUR WOULD MAKE CALIFORNIA OF
THE MODEL FOR GENDER EQUITY --
THAT IS APPROPRIATE FOR BOTH THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTOR.
AS A LATINA DAUGHTER OF
IMMIGRANT IMMIGRANTS AND POLICY
ADVOCATE MY DREAM IS TO BE A
PART OF SHAPING CALIFORNIA
A LEGISLATION AND STATE GOALS BY
ENSURING THAT WOMEN HAVE SEATS
ON APPOINTED BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS THE STATE IS
COMMITTING A TO FORMALIZING MUCH
NEEDED GENDER EQUITY WITHIN OUR
STATE.
WOMEN AND YOUNG GIRLS NEED TO
KNOW THAT THEIR SEATS FOR THEM
AT THE TABLE AND IF THEY WORK
HARD ENOUGH THEY CAN GET THERE
AND BE A PART OF SHAPING THE
STATE'S LANDSCAPE.
I WILL END WITH THE WORDS OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE RUTH BADER
CHEN HAS GINSBURG ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF POWERFUL WOMEN --
IN MALE DOMINATED SPACES.
YOU'RE GONNA CHANGE THINGS YOU
HAVE.
IF YOU GONNA CHANGE THINGS YOU
HAVE TO BE WITH THE PEOPLE WHO
HOLD THE LEVER.
THE WIND THE WPI HAS TRAINED
OVER FIFTY FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
CISGENDER TRANSGENDER WOMEN AND
NON CONFORMING INDIVIDUALS AND
IT'S FIFTEEN YEARS ALREADY TO
TAKE THAT LEVER.
OF POLICY MAKING.
WE DESERVE SEATS AT THE TABLE
WHERE DECISIONS ARE MADE ABOUT A
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE.
ONCE AGAIN I URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON THIS BE NINETY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER.
AND HELP MAKE CALIFORNIA A MODEL
OF GENDER EQUITY THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY ELSE
BECAUSE SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
TODAY.
JOHN MICHAEL FOR EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AT WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND WE WERE
HAPPY TO WORK ON THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ENSURE THAT TRANSGENDER
WOMEN ARE REFLECTED IN THEIR
SERVICE ON CORPORATE BOARDS.
WHICH WE HOPE TO SEE INCREASE AS
WELL WE ARE TO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EMAIL SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TODAY
ANYBODY SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
RUSSIANS CAUTION THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S QUIRK SILVA.
WELL GOOD MORNING TO OUR SENATOR
AND RIGHT AWAY I DO.
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS BILL ON
WOULD ASK TO BE A JOINT AUTHORED.
THE W. MOTION THING.
YES.
I DON'T SECOND.
I'M NOT SURE FOR TWO HOUSES
ALLOWED JOINT AUTHORED BUT THEY
CERTAINLY ALLOW CO AUTHOR OKAY
SO WHAT.
BUT I DO WANT TO GO BACK BECAUSE
AS WE REALLY LOOK AT HOW PEOPLE.
INVOLVED IN THEIR TIME REALLY
PROFESSIONS IT'S A SO MUCH OF
THAT HAS TO DO WITH
OPPORTUNITIES AND I KNOW ALMOST
SIXTEEN YEARS AGO I AS MY
PROFESSION I'VE ALWAYS BEEN A
CLASSROOM TEACHER.
BUT HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPLY
TO BE AS A COMMISSIONER ON IN MY
LOCAL CITY.
AND HAD TO GO THROUGH VARIOUS
INTERVIEWS AND WAS.
SELECTED TO BE ON THE PARKS AND
RECREATION SO TO BE HONEST THAT
WAS THE VERY BEGINNING OF UP
KIND OF STEPPING INTO --
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND RECREATION
COMMISSION AND THEN ALSO GOING
TO COUNSEL MANY TIMES THAT WAS
THE ONLY WOMAN IN THE ROOM I'M
NOT ONLY WITH JUST --
COUNCIL MEMBERS BUT ALSO WITH
CITY MANAGERS AND ALL THAT AND
DEPARTMENT HEADS MANY TIMES IT
WAS MYSELF MAYBE ONE OTHER ONE
WOMAN.
AND I THINK THAT THINGS ARE
CHANGING BUT WE HAVE TO BE
DIRECT ABOUT THAT CHANGE AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE NOTICE THOSE
CHANGES BECAUSE OF IT.
WOMEN ARE GETTING MORE ENGAGED
IN ACTIVE BUT WE HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO SO I APPRECIATE THIS AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ENQUEUE.
IF YOU MEASURE WHICH SPEAK.
OKAY BUT YOU ALSO SEE I THIS I
TH I THINK WE'VE BEATEN I THINK
YOU HAVE THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT
APPROACH THAT WILL BEGIN LEADING
BY EXAMPLE WITHIN OUR OWN
PURVIEW. TO PUT TO THE STATE
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS.
I RECENTLY HAD A CONSTITUENT
COME TO ME WHO FELT LIKE SHE WAS
BEING DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
ABOUT GETTING HIRED UP IN A
TRADITIONALLY MALE ORIENTED
FIELD.
I HAD GONE GOT ADDITIONAL THAT
CERTIFICATES AT IT THAN ANY
OTHER MALE APPLYING HAD --
ALONE I KINDA LOOKED INTO
LOOKING THE BOARD THAT THAT
OVERSAW THAT INTO CORPORATION.
ALL MALE BOARD SO WE KNOW THAT
SOMETIMES DOES THINGS HAVE
REPERCUSSIONS WHEN WE LOOK AT
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES TO EVEN
START COMING UP THE LADDER.
LEADERSHIP REALLY MATTERS --
SO I AM OFF I'D ALSO LIKE TO BE
A CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL BAH AND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR.
THANK YOU AND I THINK WE ALSO
KNOW THAT MUCH OF OUR AT THE
OPPORTUNITIES COME FROM
RELATIONSHIPS.
AND SO BY --
EXPANDING MORE WOMEN ON SUCH
OPPORTUNITIES THEY DEVELOP
RELATIONSHIPS WITH PEOPLE WHO
CAN ASSIST THEM GET INTO OTHER
POSITIONS SO WITHOUT ASKING
RIGHT VOTE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY.
ELEMENT THIS EGGMAN BY THAT
AMOUNT THIS EGGMAN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING BURKE
[inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
LACKING [inaudible]
LACKEY I MEDINA [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
WILL HOLD THAT ROLE OPEN FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANKS SO MUCH
[inaudible]
CENTER GLAZER.
MORNING SENATOR HOME YOU ARE
HERE TO STAY TO PRESENT S. B..
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN AND MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
THEN YOUR STAFF OF COURSE.
THAT THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE YOU
WOULD AUTHORIZE THAT DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND RECREATION. TO
DECIDE THE FUTURE OF A PROPOSED
EXPANSION OF AN OFF HIGHWAY
MOTOR VEHICLE PARKED THAT'S IN
MY DISTRICT.
THIS EXPANSION IS KNOWN AS THE
ALAMEDA TESLA EXPANSION.
AND ITS ADJACENT TO THIS
EXISTING PARK THAT WE REFER TO
AS CARNEGIE.
IT'S BEEN THERE FOR ALMOST FORTY
YEARS SO.
HEAR ABOUT THE EIGHT THE OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE PARKS IN
CALIFORNIA NOT ENOUGH.
I FOR THOSE WHO I PRACTICE THAT
ACTIVITY BUT ONE OF THEM'S IN MY
DISTRICT TEN VERY MUCH ENJOYED.
UP BY THOSE WHO I DO PARTICIPATE
IN THAT ACTIVITY.
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES THE
DEPARTMENT OVER SERIES OF
TRANSACTIONS PURCHASE THIS
ALAMEDA TESLA EXPANSION. FOR
AROUND NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY I THIS
EXPANSION PROJECT HAS BEEN MIRED
IN CONTROVERSY I EVER SINCE --
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY WILL BEEN
BAKER -- AND
AYE AYE SHE IS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHO AT THIS PROPERTY SITS
AND TO HAVE BOTH THAT I TRY DO
OBSERVE CAREFULLY THE PLAYERS
INVOLVED IN THIS CONTROVERSY
WE'VE BOTH GONE OUT. TO THE SITE
TO SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE.
BOTH IN THE EXISTING SITE IN THE
PROPOSED EXPANSION TALKED ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS.
AND WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
TOGETHER TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT CAN WE DO TO CONSTRUCTIVELY
HELP.
IN THIS DILEMMA OF THIS
EXPANSION AREA.
AND THAT THE PARTIES ARE PRETTY
WELL -- SAID
IN THEIR VIEWS ABOUT IT
[inaudible]
AND THAT --
THAT THE BEST THING THAT WE COME
UP WITH AS A CONSTRUCTIVE STEP
FORWARD ALTHOUGH ARGUABLY A
SMALL.
ONE IT'S TOO IF AT SOME POINT IN
THE IN THIS PROCESS I THE
DEPARTMENT DECIDES THAT THIS IS
NOT REALLY GOING TO LEAD TO
EXPANDING THIS PAR --
THAT THE IS THERE AN OPTION FOR
THEM TO DISPOSE OF THE LAND
APPROPRIATELY GET THAT MONEY
BACK INTO THE OFF ROAD FUND AND
TRY TO FIND ANOTHER PIECE OF
PROPERTY THAT.
CAN BE AT CONSTRUCTED FOR THOSE
WHO ENJOY THIS ACTIVITY.
AND SO IT WAS OUT OF THAT WORK
THAT THIS BILL IS BEFORE YOU
THIS BILL DOESN'T MANDATE
ANYTHING.
IT IS NOT SPEAK TO THE ACTIVITY
OF OFF ROAD RIDING IT DOES NOT
TAKE AWAY THE CURRENT OFF --
HIGHWAY VEHICLE PARKED THAT I I
MENTION.
IT SIMPLY GIVES THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT THE OPTION TO SELL
THIS PROPOSED EXPANSION AREA IF
THEY DECIDE.
IT'S IN THE PUBLIC'S BEST
INTEREST AND THEN TO RETURN THE
MONEY TO THE OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
FROM FUND FROM WHICH IT
ORIGINATED.
I THE ONLY CONDITION IS THAT
THIS LAND.
IF IT ISN'T --
IT THE DECISION IS TO NOT
DEVELOP IT WOULD BE PERMANENTLY
PRESERVE FOR CONSERVATION
PURPOSES.
I THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE LOCAL AND STATEWIDE
PRESERVATION NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
AS WELL AS SIX LOCAL PUBLIC
AGENCIES.
AND FOR THESE REASONS THAT WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR FAVORABLE
CONSIDERATION TODAY.
AND WITH ME ACTUALLY IS TO BE
JOINED BY TERESA COOK REPRESENTS
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
AND BET THAT WUERZBURG PRESIDENT
THE EAST BAY CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANTS.
SOCIETY CHAPTER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR IN THE BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FIRST PERSON SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT PLAINTIFFS IN AN ADVISER.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR ADDS READING
TO COOK ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY PARTICIPER FRASER IS VERY
PLEASED TO BE HERE THIS MORNING
IN SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN SIXTEEN
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTEEN OFFERS A
POTENTIAL SOLUTION FOR THE
ALAMEDA TUSSLE EXPANSION WHICH
AFTER TWENTY YEARS OF LITIGATION
AND HAS A STRONG.
SUPPORT OF NOT JUST THE COUNTY
BUT NUMEROUS LOCAL WHEN PART OF
SUPERVISORS VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO
OPPOSE THE EXPANSION OF CARNEGIE
CITING A CONFLICT WITH OUR
COUNTIES I POLICIES RELATIVE TO
THE ENVIRONMENT AND NATURAL
HABITATS.
THIS IS A UNIQUE ALBEIT
COMPLICATED --
SITUATION AND DISTRICTS
SITUATION SPECIFICALLY --
BUT WE DO I VERY MUCH WANT TO
ECHO OR SUPPORT FOR THOSE
POTENTIAL SOLUTION WANT TO THINK
I SENATOR GLAZER FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR FOR
OTHER CONSIDERATION.
I THINK YOU'RE BUDGET EXPERTS
BEGAN SUPPORT PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S BETH
WORST BURKE AS I'M SENATOR
GLAZERS SENATE PRESIDENT THE
EAST BAY CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
COVERING ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA
COUNTIES.
A WE THANK SENATOR GLAZERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER AND THE
OTHER ON COAUTHORS FOR THIS
BALANCED BILL THAT ALLOWS STATE
PARKS THE OPTION TO PRESERVE AN
EXCEPTIONAL PLACE TESLA.
WHILE COMPENSATING OHB AND
AVOIDING LENGTHY AND COSTLY
LITIGATION.
MY CHAPTER AND OUR STATE
ORGANIZATION SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE OF THE EXCEPTIONAL RARE
AND UNIQUE BIOLOGICAL FEATURES
OF THIS PARK.
THE SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS STATE
WHICH I BELIEVE YOU WILL HAVE
SEEN FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS
WRITTEN AT RISK CO SIGNED BY
OVER FORTY FIVE SCIENTISTS
UNIVERSITY PROFESSORS AND
LEADERS IN VARIOUS FIELDS SUCH
AS ECOLOGIES SYMBOLOGY AND
BOTANY.
AS WELL AS THE PRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF SCIENCE
AND UC BERKELEY PROFESSORS.
IT ACKNOWLEDGES THE FORTY TWO
SPECIAL STATUS WILDLIFE SPECIES
INCLUDING EIGHT STATE AND
FEDERALLY LISTED SPECIES TWENTY
EIGHT LOCALLY RARE NAY PLANTS
THIRTEEN SPECIAL STATUS SPECIES
SEVEN SENSITIVE PLANT
COMMUNITIES.
CRITICAL HABITAT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA READ LIKE IT FRAUD
ALAMEDA WHICH SNAKE CRITICAL
WILDLIFE CORDER CONNECTING NORTH
AND SOUTH MOUNT DIABLO REGIS.
ACKNOWLEDGES AUDUBON IMPORTANT
BIRD AREA AND FOR OWN CHAPTER IT
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT IT'S PART OF
OUR OWN CORRAL HOLLOW BIOLOGICAL
PRIORITY PROTECTION AREA ONLY
ONE OF FIFTEEN ALL OF ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IS
ACKNOWLEDGED AS HIGH PRIORITY
FOR PROTECTION BECAUSE OF THE
UNIQUE RESOURCES.
SORT OF LIKE TO SPEAK TO BE
ABOUT US FAQS FAIRNESS IN THE
FUTURE IN TERMS OF FACTS THERE
WAS NO PRE ACQUISITION <c.green> I</c>
ARE FOR TESLA.
SO THE STATE WAS OPERATING IN
THE DARK IN SOME SENSE IN WHAT
WAS THERE AND WHETHER IT WAS
EVEN APPROPRIATE TO BE PURCHASED
FOR OHP USE.
IT'S TRUE THAT THE STATE
RECREATIONAL VEHICLE AIRY
SCIENTISTS COLLECTED DATA INTO
ITS SURVEYS FOR BOTH CARNEGIE
AND TESLA.
HOWEVER THE ANALYSIS WAS REALLY
DONE BY THE SCIENTISTS I
REFERRED TO EARLIER IN THE
SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS STATEMENT.
THEY DETERMINED BY DOING A
THOROUGH ANALYSIS THAT THERE'S
AN ABUNDANCE OF RARE AND HIGH
VALUE NATURAL RESOURCES HERE.
AND THAT THERE'S OVERWHELMING
EVIDENCE BY COMPARING CARNEGIE
TO TESLA THAT A WHICH WE USE
SEVERELY DAMAGES NATURAL
RESOURCES AND UNDERMINES HABITAT
INTEGRITY.
THIS IS A UNIQUE PARK AND UNIQUE
CASE.
AS FAR AS THEIR EIGHT OHB PARKS
THAT'S TRUE COMPARED TO ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED STATE PARKS BUT IT
NEGLECTS TO MENTION THAT THERE
ARE MILLIONS OF ACRES OF U. S.
FOR SERVICE AND BLM LAND.
OPEN FOR A EACH USE AND PAID FOR
IN PART BY GRANTS FROM THE OHP.
THE CARNEGIE GENERAL PLAN FOR
TESLA DOESN'T IN FACT AS AN
ELEVEN HUNDRED ACRES FOR ALL HP
USE IS PROHIBITED.
IT ONLY DISALLOWS FACILITIES.
ON IN ADDITION [inaudible]
I CARNEGIE.
WE KNOW THAT ALAMEDA COUNTY AND
CALIFORNIA POPULATIONS ARE
INCREASING.
BUT THE CARNEGIE SRV A VISITOR
SHIP HAS DECLINED CONSISTENTLY
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND NOW
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN HAD ABOUT
SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND VISITORS.
WE CONTRAST THIS TO EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT WHICH HAS
BEEN INCREASING SINCE THAT TIME
AND HAD SEVENTEEN MILLION
VISITORS.
THE TERMS OF FAIRNESS WE
RECOGNIZE THAT TESLA PURCHASE
THIS THAT THE TEST WAS PURCHASED
WITH THE INTENT THAT ABUSE AS
OHP.
BUT THIS WAS BEFORE ALL THE
FACTS WERE KNOWN IN THIS CASE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT A WHICH WE SHOULD
BE COMPENSATED THAT ALL PROCEEDS
FROM THE SALE SHOULD GO BACK TO
A WAGE FEE FOR PURCHASE OF LAND.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL HELP
PREVENT A LENGTHY AND COSTLY
LITIGATION BATTLE SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE BENEFICIAL BOTH TO THE
CONSERVATION OHB COMMUNITIES.
AS FAR AS THE FUTURE GOES I HAVE
TO ASK WHEN YOU FAX COME TO
LIGHT DO WE ALLOW
REPRESENTATIVES TO MAKE THE BEST
POSSIBLE DECISION FOR US NOW AND
FOR THE FUTURE. ONE HUNDRED
YEARS FROM NOW WE'LL STATE PARKS
ROLE IN THIS HOLD UP.
BILLY EVEN HAVE THE OPTION TO
DETERMINE WHAT WOULD BE THE BEST
POSSIBLE DECISION IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST.
AND FINALLY I'D LIKE TO QUOTE
FROM THE SCIENTISTS WHOSIGNED
THE STATEMENT YOU SAID SOME OF
THE BEST AND MOST FORWARD
THINKING WORK OF OUR STATE.
IN RESEARCH EDUCATION AND
GOVERNMENT HAS RESULTED IN THE
PRESERVATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
NATURAL WONDERS FOR THE FUTURE.
WE URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON SB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN TO ALLOW STATE
PARKS TO EXERCISE THEIR BEST
JUDGMENT IN THIS DISPOSITION OF
THIS UNIQUE PLACE IN THIS UNIQUE
CASE.
THANK YOU THINK YOU'RE MUCH
ANYBODY ELSE BECAUSE SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TODAY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR OF THE
LITTLE NOT BEHALF OF THE STATE
WAY CALIFORNIA PLANTS IDEAS WELL
AS ONGOING CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING WORKING CLEAN FOR
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARILYN
SAY TURN RUSSELL.
I'M ON THE BOARD OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT WHICH SUBMITTED A
LETTER IN.
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT TO ASISTIR
YEAH XIN YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE
OUR DOCUMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
EMILY JOINER I LIVE IN LIVERMORE
AND SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
TRI VALLEY TRAIL BLAZERS LOCAL
EQUESTRIAN GROUP.
WE URGE A YES VOTE FOR YOU TO
PROTECT OUR LIKE THINK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MY NAME IS DAVID LAN --
THE LITTLE MORE HERITAGE KILL
SUPPORT SAYS THE ALONI AUDUBON
GROUP SUPPORTS THIS.
MEMBERS OF THE FRIENDS WILL
NEVER MORE SUPPORT SAYS THE I'M
PART OF THE FRIENDS OF THE
ARROYO WE SUPPORT THIS THAN EVER
MORE HILL HIKER SUPPORTS THIS.
AND FRIENDS OF THE BEEN YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER SPEND
SOME SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
SOCIETY OF AMERICAN INDIANS AYE
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON SB.
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN I THINK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE PUBLIC AUBURN
REPRESENTING THE MORE THAN A
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF SAY NOT
DOUBLE INSTRUCTS SPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CATHERINE PHILLIPS FOR SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
CELESTINA JOAQUIN COUNTY --
IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF FRIENDS
OF TESLA PARK WHICH IS AN
ALLIANCE THAT INCLUDES GROUPS IN
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY INCLUDING
SANTA AUDUBON SOCIETY.
AND THE DELTA SIERRA GROUP AT
THIS SIERRA CLUB WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS WISE AND FAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LIKE XIN.
LARA CULTURAL ON BEHALF OF EAST
BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY INTEREST BEGAN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL TODAY
.
MADAM CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TERRY MIKHAIL WITH
AARON READ NOT SO SEATS.
REPRESENTING A COALITION OF OFF
HIGHWAY MEET VEHICLE OF
RECREATION STE [inaudible]
UP.
SENATOR GLAZER HAS A WELL
DESERVED REPUTATION FOR BRINGING
DISPIRITO ARTIE'S TOGETHER AND
TRYING TO WORK OUT DIFFICULT
SITUATIONS --
I KNOW HE HAS TRIED ON THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATION.
A UNFORTUNATELY IN THE SEVENTY
CLIENTS THAT WE REPRESENT.
I KNOW OF NONE IN WHICH THERE IS
MORE PASSION IN MORE
DISAGREEMENT.
THEN WHEN WE DEAL WITH OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION AND
COMMUNITIES THAT OPPOSE IT.
BUT MADAM CHAIRMAN [inaudible]
LAST YEAR.
WE SPENT THE ENTIRE SESSION
[inaudible]
MEETING [inaudible]
WEEKLY.
HUNDREDS OF MEETINGS THOUSANDS
OF HOURS TO REVISIT THE OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA.
UNTIL LAST YEAR THE PROGRAM WAS
SUNSET ID EVERY FIVE YEARS.
BUT AFTER LAST YEAR'S SUCCESSFUL
LEGISLATION WITH SENATOR ALLEN.
THAT WAS STRONGLY SUPPORTED.
BY BOTH ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND
THE OHP COMMUNITY.
THE SUNSET WAS REMOVED.
AND IT WAS REMOVED BECAUSE
BECAUSE IT IS CLEARLY UNDERSTOOD.
THAT NO PART OF PARKS.
HAS A GREATER RESOURCE OF
SCIENTISTS AND ENVIRONMENTALISTS.
THEN THE OVERWEIGHT FEE PROGRAM
IT'S IT SHOULD BE NOTED HOWEVER.
THEN ON SEPTEMBER THIRD WHILE
THAT NEGOTIATION WAS GOING ON
THE FRIENDS OF TESLA WALKED AWAY
FROM THE DISCUSSIONS.
AND DECIDED NOT TO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
AND IN THE MEMO THAT THEY SHARED
WITH THE COMMUNITY.
THEY SAID THAT INSTEAD OF
SUPPORTING IT THEY WOULD RATHER.
PUT THEIR RESOURCES INTO THE
FACT TO THE POSSIBILITY OF THE
ALTAMONT LANDFILL OPEN SPACE
COMMITTEE.
BUYING THIS PROPERTY.
NOW IT'S INTERESTING
[inaudible] TWO REASONS. ONE IS
THAT ONE OF THE MANDATES OF THAT
COMMITTEE IS THAT THEY CANNOT
ALLOW ANY OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
RECREATION.
THE SECOND ISSUE.
IS THAT THAT COMMITTEE AS OF
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SEVENTH.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN HAD THIRTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE FUND.
WHEN ASKING THE PARK'S WHAT THE
VALUE OF THESE THIRTY ONE
HUNDRED ACRES ARE [inaudible]
OR IS [inaudible]
A THEY SAID.
IT WOULD BE A GREAT STEEL AT
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION.
I BRING THAT UP BECAUSE THIS
PARTICULAR LEGISLATION.
SAYS THAT THIS PROPERTY CAN BE
SOLD AT BELOW MARKET VALUE.
AT BELOW MARKET VALUE.
AND IT IS CLEARLY INTENDED.
BUT THIS PARTICULAR ENTITY
PURCHASE THIS PARK [inaudible]
SECONDLY.
SENATOR GLAZER IS VERY FAIR.
BUT WITH THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
THE BILL DELIBERATELY AVOIDS
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION.
BUT THE GROUP.
THAT DIRECTS.
THE ACQUISITION AND THE CARE OF
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION.
IS AN OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
COMMISSION WITHIN PARKS.
UNDER THIS BILL.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY BYPASSED.
THE DECISION ON THE SALE IS MADE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS.
ALL OF US WHO HAVE WORKED ON
THIS ISSUE [inaudible]
RECOGNIZE.
THAT OHB HAS LONG BEEN
CONSIDERED THE RED HEADED
STEPCHILD OF PAR.
YOU COULD WRAP ABSOLUTELY AND
WHEN IT WAS DESIGNED IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
BY CHAPPY EASY BURKE THEY VERY
DELIBERATELY CREATED A SEPARATE
DIVISION OF OHP TO DEAL WITH THE
SITUATIONS.
BECAUSE THEY SAID PARKS HAD
DIFFERENT INTERESTS.
IN CLOSING I WOULD JUST SAY THIS.
THE ENTIRE PROPERTY HAS BEEN
MAPPED. SEVEN YEARS MAPPING THIS
PROPERTY EVERY SQUARE FOOT HAS
BEEN MAPPED.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN MORE
THAN FAIR WITH WORKING WITH THE
DIVISION IN TERMS OF HOW THIS
WILL BE USED. ELEVEN HUNDRED
ACRES OF THIS TWO THOUSAND ACRES
WILL NOT BE USED FOR OHP IT WILL
BE SET ASIDE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THINK YOU'RE
MUCH NEXT PERSON AGAIN
OPPOSITION CLEAR MADAM CHAIR
CAPPING LEDGE REPRESENT ANY OFF
ROAD VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE
COALITION A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION OF OF WRITERS --
WE TO MR MCHALE DID AN EXCELLENT
JOB OF EXPLAINING OUR
POSITIONING JUST TO REITERATE
THAT LAST YEAR ON S. B. TWO
FORTY NINE BY SENATOR ALLEN THAT
WAS A YEAR LONG PROCESS AND IT
WAS A PAINFUL PROCESS AT TIMES.
AND THERE WAS A REAL TUG AND
PULL BETWEEN THE BE --
CONTINUATION OF OFF ROAD VEHICLE
RECREATION PURSUIT AS WELL AS
THE ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION AND
VERY PROUD TO SAY THAT WE ALL
WORKED COLLABORATIVE --
TO TRY TO FIND SOLUTIONS INC.
YOU'LL SEE BY SOME OF THE
PICTURES OF THE BEEN HANDED OUT --
THE KIND OF WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE AT THE CARNEGIE AREA AND SO
WE WOULD JUST URGE YOU TO
RESPECT THE PROCESS THAT YOU
WERE PART UP LAST YEAR.
AND CONTINUING --
SP TWO FORTY NINE THERE'S ALSO
TO BE AN OUT REACH US
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AS A AS PART
OF SP.
TWO FORTY NINE AND THAT WOULD BE
A PROPER PLACE FOR SOME OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS TO CONTINUE BUT
SHORT CIRCUITING IT AND BY
PASSING IT.
IS VERY PROBLEMATIC AND WHILE
THIS IS PRESENTED AS A DISTRICT
ISSUE IT REALLY IS A MATTER OF
STATEWIDE CONCERN THESE ARE
STATE PROPERTIES AND ONCE YOU
START DOWN THIS ROAD AND SET THE
PRECEDENT.
ARM BAND REALLY EVERY STATE
PROPERTY.
IS SUBJECT TO DISTRICT WENT SO
WE WOULD ASK FOR EVERYONE TO
WORK TOGETHER AND TO CONTINUE.
PALM WHAT THE WHAT THE PLANT YOU
THINK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYBODY ELSE BEEN IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL TODAY. TO THE
MICROPHONE NAME AND AFFILIATION
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING COMMISSIONERS DAVID
PICKET REPRESENTING DISTRICT --
THIRTY SIX AMERICAN MOTORCYCLIST
ASSOCIATION DISTRICT THIRTY
SEVEN DISTRICT THIRTY EIGHT CAL
FOUR WHEEL DRIVE ASSOCIATION
OASIS FOR KIDS.
AND A HOST OF OTHERS WHERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
AND FOR CORRECTIVE PURPOSES IT
IS NOT A PARK.
THE LEGAL DEFINITION AS A STATE
VEHICLE RECREATION AREA.
THAT WAS BUILT DESIGNED AND
PURCHASED FOR OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLE RECREATION AND A LEGAL
AND MANAGED.
ANYWAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SIR [inaudible]
OKAY.
A QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
HURT AND THIS --
THIS BILL HAS CERTAINLY --
INSPIRED OF LOT OF OF INTEREST
FOR AN AREA THAT.
FEW PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT I'M AND I
HAPPEN TO KNOW ABOUT IT BECAUSE
IT IT. THREE MY DISTRICT TOUCHES
IT I'M AT THE TOP OF THE ULTIMA.
I'M SO.
MY MY I THINK MY ISSUE IS AROUND
THE ISSUE OF FAIRNESS AND AND
SOME THINGS ARE GLAZER I HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THIS.
AND IS AB THORNY ISSUE THAT THE
LAND WAS PURCHASED.
THROUGH THIS FUND BY THE OFF
ROAD PEOPLE WHO USE IT --
I GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU
SENATOR GLAZER IS WOULD YOU BE
WILLING. TWO TAKE OUT AT THE
SECTION THAT SAYS THAT IT CAN BE
SOLD FOR BELOW MARKET VALUE
BECAUSE AS WE ALL KNOW AND I
CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN PART OF
SALES OF A CITY PROPERTIES THAT
YOU CAN SELL FOR A DOLLAR --
TO BE ABLE TO GET RID OF
SOMETHING WHICH OF COURSE THEN
WOULD NOT --
COME ANYWHERE NEAR SINCE THE
NINE MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
USED OUT OF FEES FEES PEOPLE
PAID THINKING THEY'RE GONNA HAVE
OFF ROAD AND NOW WE'RE SAYING.
AND AND ALSO POINT OUT THAT
THEY'RE STILL UP A SINGLE CASE
ARE STILL LITIGATION GOING ON SO
THE DETERMINATION OF WHAT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN WITH THIS PIECE
OF LAND.
STILL UNCERTAIN BUT YOU'RE
SAYING IF.
IF IN FACT S. FOUND THAT CAN'T
BE USED FOR THIS.
THEN IT COULD BE SOLD. FOR BELOW
MARKET VALUE.
THAT MONEY THEN TO BE USED TO
PURCHASE OTHER AREAS.
ARE YOU WILLING OR WHAT WAS THE
REASONING FOR ALLOWING THE STATE.
SELES AT BELOW MARKET VALUE
WHICH AGAIN BIKE BY DEFINITION.
IS LESS THAN THE NINE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT.
THAT HONEST CALIFORNIANS HAVE
PAID INTO A FUND THAT WE SAID WE
USE FOR ONE THING.
MANAGER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION I IT WASN'T MY
INTENTION TO SHORT.
CHANGE THE FUND THAT DIES YOU
HAD CORRECTLY STATED IT'S
COLLECTED THESE FEES OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME.
OUT WHAT WE WERE DOING WITH THE
BILL WAS REFLECTING WHAT.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS.
I THAT WHEN A PROPERTIES IT'S TO
BE ROUTE PRESERVE FOR OPEN SPACE
THAT THAT'S PART OF THE THE
CURRENT LAW AND WEAKENING
COOPERATE BUT I I WOULD BE
WILLING --
TO I HAD TO DELETE THAT IF THAT
IS WHAT YOU WERE ASKING DELETE
AT LESS THAN FAIR MARKET VALUE.
AYE AND AND DATA ELIMINATE THAT
PHRASE I IT'S NOT MY INTENTION
TO SHORT CHANGE THE FUN I THINK
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF A PARKING
REDWOOD VALLEY ALL THE ELEMENTS
INCLUDING WHEN THEY GET THE
MONEY BACK AND I CERTAINLY WOULD.
WANT TO GET THE MONEY BACK SO I
I'D BE HAPPY TO DO THAT YES
[inaudible]
OKAY.
YES MISTER PATTERSON --
YOU STATED ARE THE TEARS.
CERTAIN LAW THAT YOU AND
COOPERATED.
WITH THAT STATEMENT.
WOULD TAKING THE STATEMENT OUT.
A STILL ALLOW THE PROCESS TO
SELL IT FOR LESS [inaudible]
THEN.
THE MARKET VALUE BECAUSE YOU
STATE ITSUSE I GUESS IS NOW
DETERMINE TO BE OPEN.
IF U. DESIGNATED FOR OPEN YOU
DON'T YOU OPEN.
THE DIRECT --
LIKELIHOOD --
THAT SOME AGENCY DIVISION OR
DEPARTMENT IS GOING TO DECIDE TO
SELL IT FOR LESS.
THEN OF FAIR MARKET VALUE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION AYE I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO IT I'M HEARING THAT
QUESTION FROM THE CHAIR NOW I
IT'S NOT MY INTENTION TO SHORT
CHANGE THE FUND --
SO IT IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
STAFF IN OUR UNDERSTANDING IF WE
EXPLICITLY SAY IT MUST BE SOLD
FOR MARKET VALUE THEN THAT WOULD
BE THE LAW WHICH WOULD THEN
CIRCUMVENT AND THE OTHER LAW
THAT SAYS IT MAY BE SOLD OR MUST
BE SOLD FOR LESS THAN MARKET
VALUE FOR CONSERVATION.
HIT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IF YOU
SELL IT I MEAN FOR THE
CONSERVATION BUT BUT THE THEN
NINE MILLION I THINK IS THE PART
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT
THEN MUST BE ABLE TO GO BACK. TO
PURCHASE OTHER LAND FOR OFF
[inaudible]
ROAD VEHICLE [inaudible]
ACCESS.
I GUESS THE ONLY AND MY ONLY
REACTION TO AT THE MOMENT IS
THAT.
AS WE KNOW APPRAISALS ARE DONE
BASED ON SOME THAT.
DESCRIPTION OF HOW THAT.
PIECE OF LAND MIGHT BE USED
[inaudible]
AND THAT [inaudible]
I YOU KNOW WHAT RAISES A FLAG
WITH ME IS THAT WE WOULDN'T WANT
AN APPRAISAL TO BE DONE IS IF
YOU'RE GONNA BUILD A SUBDIVISION
OUT THERE.
BECAUSE THAT WOULD REALLY BE A
FAIR.
APPRAISAL OF WHAT THAT LAND
WHATEVER EVENTUALLY BE USED FOR
APPROVED FOR SELF.
BECAUSE IT GOES BACK.
TO THE DEFINITIONS THAT ARE USED
IN TERMS OF FIRE.
HOW THAT MARKET VALUE IS
DETERMINED IF THE MARKET VALUE
IS DETERMINED BASED ON
CONSERVATION LAND?
THEN I'D BE COMFORTABLE WITH
THAT BECAUSE THAT WE BE CLEAR
HOW IT'S BEING VALUED --
BUT THAT WOULD BICU THE
CAUTION THAT I WOULD PUT FORWARD
ON THAT [inaudible]
AB WHEN.
WHAT'S BEFORE US IS YOU'RE
WILLING TO TAKE OUT LANGUAGE.
BUT I DO ARE YOU WILLING TO PUT
IN SPECIFIED LANGUAGE.
THAT IT WILL NOT BE SOLD FOR
LESS THAN MARKET VALUE.
BUT ONCE AGAIN I I'D BE
COMFORTABLE IF WE COULD DEFINE
THE TERMS THAT I'M NOT SURE I
WERE ABLE TO DEFINE THE TERMS AT
THE MOMENT.
AND AGAIN I HAD NO ONE THAT I
DON'T BE DIFFICULT BUT THAT.
BUT THE REALITY HERE IS TERMS.
LANGUAGE AND IDENTIFICATION
LANGUAGE MEANS SOMETHING WE
HEARD EARLIER FROM.
UP BOB BUT WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
WHICH SAID.
THAT THIS IS AN OFF ROAD VEHICLE
[inaudible]
DESIGNATION AND TO DESIGNATED
OPEN SPACE AND AVAILABLE FOR
CONSERVATION SEEMS TO ME TO
BASICALLY INVITE --
THE DEVALUATION OF THAT PROPERTY
SO FOR A LOT REASONS I'M REALLY
REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE WITH WHERE
WE ARE HERE.
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK WE'RE
GETTING TO HAVE A RESOLUTION OF
ANY ANY REAL FAIRNESS.
SIR I'D I DON'T GO THROUGH THE
CHAIR I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
APPRAISAL THAT WAS.
DONE FOR THE ORIGINAL PURCHASE
PRICE WHEN THEY STARTED TO
ASSEMBLE THESE UNITS AND I DON'T.
I DON'T KNOW WHY.
AND WHAT WAS USED TO AND WHETHER
THAT APPROPRIATE SOUL WAS
DEFINED.
AS AN OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE PARKER
SOMETHING DIFFERENT I JUST DON'T
KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE COUNTY HAS
ANY IDEA OF THAT THAT THAT THAT
THAT HOSE PURCHASES HAPPENED I
THINK IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES
SO QUITE SO QUITE A LONG TIME
AGO.
LOOK MY LIFE INSURANCE TOO TO
YOU IS THAT I IT'S NOT MY
INTENTION TO SHORT CHANGE THE
FUND.
I THAT I'D LIKE TO ADD THAT GET
THE BEST VALUE THEY COULD.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO CREATE A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE THE
DEFINITION OF MARKET VALUE IS A
SUBDIVISION.
BECAUSE IT'S A WIDE EXPANSE OF
LAND IN THE COUNTY MAY HAVE ITS
OWN FOR HOUSE EVERY FIFTY ACRES.
AND THEN YOU GET A SITUATION
WHERE THE MARKET VALUE WAS TWO
HUNDRED HOMES AND I I DON'T
THINK THAT'S FAIR EITHER CELLS
TRYING TO FIND THAT RIGHT
BALANCE.
I THINK THE I THINK THEY THE
IDEA THAT THAT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE --
APPRAISED AT AT THE SUBDIVISION
I THINK IS A VERY EXCESSIVE --
AND AUTUMN.
DETERMINATION HERE ARE JUST AS
EXCESSIVE AS SAYING THAT WE'RE
GOING -- TO
APPRAISE THIS IS CONSERVATION
LAND.
THIS HAS GOT TO BE AN OPEN
MARKET FREE MARKET.
A ASSESSMENT OF THIS THAT'S MY
FIRST CONCERN I DON'T THINK
WE'RE GETTING THERE HERE.
MY SECOND MY SECOND THE CONCERN.
REALLY IS THE EVEN IF YOU MADE
THE FOR THE FUND HOLE THE IDEA
THAT YOU CAN FIND A SIGNIFICANT
REPLACEMENT WITH THIS KIND OF
VALUE IN THIS KIND OF COMMITMENT
BY OFF ROAD FOLKS --
I JUST THINK IS OF UP A REAL.
UP A DIFFICULT POSSIBILITY I'M
BEGINNING TO FEEL AS IF THIS IS
SIMPLY A MANEUVER.
IN ORDER TO TAKE THE GROUND AND
TURNED INTO SOMETHING ELSE
NOTWITHSTANDING YOUR CLAIMS THAT
YOU JUST BASICALLY TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING HERE BUT IT DOES FEEL
LIKE THAT TO ME AND I I'M
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THAT.
AND I AND I DON'T THINK.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY HAS BEEN
OF LESSEN FORTHCOMING THAT IS
THAT IS THE PURPOSE.
THAT IS THE PURPOSE IS TO TAKE
THIS LAND AND DO SOMETHING ELSE
WITH IT.
THAT'S THE PURPOSE NOT RIGHT NOW.
THAT THAT UP SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE NOT WITH THE BILL BUSINESS
IS TED THAT THE PURPOSE THAT THE
LAND WAS PURCHASED.
THE DESIRE FOR THAT PROPONENTS
IS THAT IT BE USED FOR
CONSERVATION.
I THINK THAT THAT.
FOR ASSEMBLY WOMAN BAKER AND I I
HAD THE THE MOTIVATION BEHIND
THIS BILL IS DUE AT THAT THE
THESE WARRING PARTIES BEEN
WHORING FOR A LONG LONG TIME AYE
AYE AND I UNDERSTAND SIR THAT
YOUR YOUR AND AND WE SIMPLY WANT
A PET RIGHT NOW WE'VE THAT WITH
PARTY.
LIKE RATTLE PIECE I UNDERSTAND I
HIM BEAT WELL WHEN WE MET WE MET
WITH THE FIRE BUT THE DIRECTORS
APARTMENT PARTS OF IRAQ.
A THAT THAT THEIR THEIR VIEW WAS
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE THAT AS AN
OPTION STEVE.
CATHERINE WE MET TOGETHER AND
AND THAT THAT THE ONLY WAY TO
GIVE THEM THAT OPTION IF THEY
DECIDED THAT THEY HAD ENOUGH OF
THE LITIGATION.
WAS TOO I WAS TO MOVE THIS
DISTRICT BILL.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING
TODAY DOESN'T MANDATE ANYTHING
DOESN'T TAKE A SIDE IN THE
DISPUTES --
AS I SAID I HAVE A AT THE
FACILITY IN MY DISTRICT TODAY I
HAVE MANY CONSTITUENTS TO ENJOY
IT.
I AM AND IT'S NOT MY ATTEMPT TO
CURTAIL THAT ACTIVITY --
IT'S TO GIVE AN OPTION THE
DEPARTMENT THAT THEY GET THAT
THEY DECIDE TO SAY ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH THAT.
I THOUGHT THAT THE BILL GIVES
THEM THAT OPTION NOW MANDATE
WHATSOEVER OKAY [inaudible]
FROM.
AGAIN I WOULD BE WILLING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
BUT I WILL NOT.
SUPPORT MOVING FORWARD OUT OF
THE NEXT COMMITTEE AND I SAID ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
IF WE HAVE NOT RESOLVE THE ISSUE
UP I THINK THE NINE MILLION
DOLLARS NEED TO BE MADE WHOLE
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
IF IT CAN'T BE THROUGH THE SALE.
THEN I THINK THEN I THINK THE
INTERESTED PARTIES IN
CONSERVATION NEED TO FIND
ANOTHER WAY. TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THAT FUND HOLE OF THAT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS.
I AMIF IT CAN'T BE THROUGH THE
LAND SALE THEN I THINK THAT
NEEDS TO BE ANOTHER MECHANISM IN
PLACE.
SO WHILE THAT WE CANNOT REWRITE
THE BILL TODAY I UNDERSTAND IS A
THORNY ISSUE AND I'VE CERTAINLY
HEARD ABOUT IT FOR YEARS TO AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU GUYS ARE
TRYING.
TO A THREAD THAT NEEDLE --
SO I WILL SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT I
AM.
I WANT EVERYONE TO BE VERY CLEAR
THAT I AM SAYING FURTHER AND I
WILL --
SERVING MAKE THAT VERY WELL
KNOWN THAT IF WE CAN'T IF YOU
CAN'T.
WORKING WITH LEDGE COUNCIL FIND
A LEGAL WAY TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THAT NINE MILLION DOLLAR THAT
WENT INTO THE PURCHASE OF THAT
LAND. TO MAKE THAT FUND HOLE IF
THAT LAND THEN SHOULD BE PUT
INTO CONSERVATION.
AT FAIR ENOUGH I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION
THAT WOULD BE MY INTENTION TO
MATCH YOUR DESIRES IS WEAKENED
THE BILL FOUGHT WITH THAT
CONDITION I'M.
I WILL BE SUPPORTED MR POTATO
I'LL MOVE THE BILL.
LIKE TO ASK OF THE OPPONENTS.
IS THIS MERELY A THE A NINE
MILLION DOLLAR MAKE COAL.
AND IF THAT TAKES PLACE DOES
THAT SATISFY YOUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR ASKING IT ARE.
I DO WANT TO SOME LOCAL I. I DO
NOT BELIEVE.
IN ANY WAY THAT SENATOR GLAZER.
WANTS TO ROB OHP I MEAN IT'S
IT'S NOT AS MAKE UP AND I JUST
THINK IT WAS.
IT DOESN'T WORK RIGHT.
THE NINE MILLION DOLLARS DOESN'T
MAKE THE THE NINE MILLION
DOLLARS WAS A PURCHASE IN.
NINETEEN NINETY THE VALUE OF
THAT PROPERTY NOW AT A LOW VALUE
IS TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR HP TO GO OUT AND BUY ANOTHER
PROPERTY THEY HAVE TO BUY IT.
AT TWENTY EIGHTEEN PRICES NOT
NINETEEN NINETY PRICE.
SO WE WOULD SAY THAT IF SENATOR
GLAZERS BILL IS TO MOVE FORWARD
IT'S GOING TO BE THE MARKET
VALUE.
WHICH PARKS WILL DETERMINE THAT
IT'S CLOSER TO TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS THEN.
NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THOUGHT ABOUT THIS EGGMAN BY
THAT AMOUNT IS EGGMAN AYE
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO BURKE.
BURKE AYE FRAZIER [inaudible]
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO MEDINA MEDINA AYE
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
ALRIGHT ASISTIR LARA ANYWHERE IN
THE BUILDING.
OKAY OF WHICH I THINK MR MEDINA
DEMONS BROKEN BEAK ADDED TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IF THEY SO MOVE.
AND OKAY SO JUST ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND THEN ON S. B.. NINE
EIGHTY FOUR BY WE MISS SKINNER.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
S. B. AND NINE EIGHTY FOUR BURKE
[inaudible]
BURKE I MEDINA MEDINA AYE. FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR BURKE.
BURKE AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE.
DO WE KNOW HOW CLOSE MISTER
LARA'S
[inaudible]
IT IS --
ISRAEL'S WEST OKAY
. FOR MR WHAT
IF MISTER PATTERSON COULD TAKE
THE REINS I THINK WE CAN
DISPENSE OF THE LAST BILL THAT
HAS THE SUPPORT SUPPORT POSITION.
AND THE MAN CHAIR PLEASE PRESENT
THANK YOU I LIKE TO PRESENT
TODAY ON BEHALF OF BUT MISTER
LARA AND I THINK WE HAVE SOME
LATE MINUTE DEVELOPMENTS THAT
MISTER MERCER CHEESE BILL WHO WE
HEARD A COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND
MISTER LARA'S BILL HAVE.
A THEY HAVE AGREED TO COME
TOGETHER THIS DEALS WITH THE
STATE AUDITOR.
OF AND THAT BASICALLY SAYS THAT
I THE OTHER DAY SAID JUST LET
JAY LACK KNOW IF THEY'RE GOING
TO START DOING SOME PRELIMINARY
WORK OUT IN OUR LOCAL A
JURISDICTIONS --
AND AND THEN WOULD BE ABLE TO
REPORT BACK TO US BEFORE THEY
DID A FULL BLOWN UP AUDIT.
MOST IN A SECOND IS THERE ANY --
OTHER VOICES IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WITH CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PATH AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
BUT A MONTH THIS EGGMAN ELEMENT
THAT'S EGGMAN AYE PATTERSON
[inaudible]
PATTERSON I BURKE [inaudible]
FRAZIER.
LACKEY LACKEY AYE.
BURKE BURKE I MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE QUIRK SILVA.
KIRK SILVA AYE.
ALRIGHT --
THAT CONCLUDES.
THAT CONCLUDES --
THE CURRENT BUSINESS WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN.
I THINK MR DID I THINK YOU GOT
THE MALL I THINK WE'LL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR MR FRAZIER FOR
FIVE MINUTES
.
OKAY OKAY YOU MADE IT YOU MADE
IT.
OKAY A WE HAVE BOTTOM AND OF
MISTER FRAZIER IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ADD ON HERE OKAY HERE.
HAVE A CONSENT [inaudible]
I OF FRAZIER FOR CONSENT
[inaudible]
FRAZIER AYE.
OKAY --
MISTER BRAZIER --
SKINNER S. B..
NINE EIGHTY FOUR FRAZIER RAZOR I
MISTER FRAZIER MISTER LARA
TWELVE NINETY THREE BY FRAZIER
AYE.
FRAZIER GLAZIER ELEVEN US THAT
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN MASSIVE SHARE
WHAT THE REQUEST AS OF THE
AUTHOR THAT THE CHAIR --
INFORM THE AUTHOR THAT WELL IT
COULD MOVE TODAY THAT --
WE WOULD NOT BE IN FAVOR OF
SELLING THAT LAND AT LESS THAN
MARKET VALUE AND THAT THE OFF
ROAD VEHICLE FIND IT MUST BE --
WE MADE HOLE TO THAT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS --
IN ORDER FORCE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL GOING FORWARD THROUGH THE
NEXT COMMITTEE AND MISTER
GLAZIER MADE THAT COMMITMENT.
WITH THAT THANK YOU FOR THOSE
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS TO THE
AUTHOR.
WOMAN I THINK FRAZIER AYE